Pamela Joseph returns to salvage what
she can after flood waters wrecked our
home
a single room is all that's left of our
six bedroom Bungalow and it's close to
oppressivism
when Night comes I have to go somewhere
else to sleep my house is finished
the government has promised help but so
far it hasn't reached tens of thousands
of people across Nigeria
we feel what we have taken is advocate
for at the moment but
the subnationals also have the
responsibility to see that uh they are
their their their citizens are being you
know supported
some flood victims say nothing is being
done
sincerely there is no app from
governments sincerely this used to be
someone's bedroom Before the Flood the
debris here is what's left of it and of
38 other houses that was Swept Away the
foundations of some of the buildings are
in the middle of this River
the flights between June and November
who are among the worst to hit Nigeria
in half a century
infrastructure-like roads and bridges
have been damaged or swept away two
months after the disaster officials are
still taking stock of the damage
but the government says it needs two
billion dollars now to fix damage
infrastructure
analysts say it's clear authorities at
all levels were ill-prepared for the
disaster
they just don't have an incentive to
address this because when you have a
system where emergency funds are
released without accountability we have
processes where there's no proper
procurement for those funds A lot of
people benefit from this there's a whole
political economy around this flood I
worry that we might not even be able to
recover quick enough before the next
vlog with politicians focused on the
general elections in two months
some flood victims say they are worried
their troubles are only just beginning
Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera or bogoro